-Oh, thank you guys so much.
Hi. How are you? Whoo.
[ Audience cheering ]
Yeah, hi, guys. My name is Pete.
This is my face.
I look like a dentist.
[ Laughter ]
I have a vibe like,
"I'm not just your dentist
I'm your friend."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, hard-core guy.
I know it's weird that my hand
are free, cause I look lik
a guy that's holding onto
his virginity super tight.
[ Laughter ]
But, oh, no, I smash.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'm all about respecting women
and smashing.
[ Laughter ]
Sometimes I'm like,
"Yeah, do you like that?
Okay, just checking."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
I got mistaken for being, like
a really bad guy the other day
I was in one of those colleg
campus, like, safe-space
coffee shops. And --
And I burned my mouth
on my coffee really bad.
And I go, "Ugh!"
And this girl, she goes,
"Excuse me,
but that is toxic masculinity.
[ Light laughter ]
And I was like, "Oh, I'm me.
I'll take any masculinity.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you.
Yeah.
I was like, "Thank you so much."
And then she wanted to argue
with me. And I was like,
"I'm sorry, I can't.
I'm doing a conflict cleanse."
[ Laughter ]
And then she was like "What?
And I was like, "Mindfulness."
[ Laughter ]
I think I'm like the furthes
thing from a toxic man.
Look at me.
I'm like pure joy in a person.
I look like if CBD oil
had a mascot.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Like you're just a few drops
away from a smile.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I'm like?
Have you ever been sitting dow
on your toilet,
and your bathroom door is shut
And you're like,
"I am all alone."
And all of a sudden, your cat'
paw slips under the door.
And he's like, "No, you're not
I want to be in there
with you so bad!"
[ Grunts ]
[ Laughter ]
That's like me
but with friendship.
[ Laughter ]
Or have you guys ever
been in a stadium,
you have your tickets
in your hand.
See somebody's sitting
in your seat?
Nightmare, right?
Not for this guy.
I'm like, "Oh, we can share.
[ Laughter ]
I'm like, "Shoulders in.
It's a snugglestorm."
[ Laughter ]
Here's a life hack.
If you're everybody
at a movie theater,
stadium, just siting on the bus,
you make direct eye contac
with your seat mates.
And then you wiggle.
[ Laughter ]
You'll get your own row.
Yeah.
[ Applause ]
That's actually the best way t
avoid conflict in life, right?
All my friends are studyin
jiu-jitsu, MMA, kickboxing
You don't got to do all that
Just make eye contact. Wiggle.
[ Laughter ]
No one will fight you.
I was in a bar the other night
I spilled this man's beer.
He goes, "Hey!
You want to take this outside?
I was like, "Be right there.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I got outside.
I was like, "Where is he?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, stranger?
Hooty-hoo.
You want to wiggle together?
I need to get
some clip-on hair extensions
just so I can accentuate
my wiggle, you know?
You want to go, bro?
[ Blows sharply ]
[ Laughter ]
Except I started
losing my hair up here,
so I'd have to clip them ont
the crown like a wedding veil.
[ Light laughter ]
Yeah. I didn't know
that I was going bald,
but I was sitting at my kitche
table with my girlfriend,
who's real.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, that laughter was hurtful.
But we were sitting there,
and I leaned under
our kitchen table lamp.
And it shined on my bald spot.
And my bald spot was like --
♪♪ Ah ♪♪
And my girlfriend noticed,
because she has eyes.
[ Laughter ]
And my girlfriend
is one of the kindest people
that I've ever met in my life.
But here's how
she decided to tell me.
She reached over and touched
the skin of my bald spot.
And then she looked me in th
eyes, and she goes, "Oh, no.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, oh, oh, no.
Oh, no."
And I was like,
"Never make that noise again!"
[ Laughter ]
Then she goes, "But, babe, i
I had something wrong with me,
I would want you to tell me.
Yeah, every part of my sou
was like, "It's a trap."
[ Laughter ]
No woman wants you
to notice her flaws
and then communicate with he
about them.
No. Blinders on.
Snitches get stitches.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you, yeah.
[ Applause ]
No woman would want
the man that loves her
to be like, "Oh, mustache.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh, oh, oh."
"That's a sombrero
for your mustache."
[ Laughter ]
If you did that,
you'd be dead by sundown.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you very much. Thank you
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
I thought that was really funny.
Pete Lee, everybody!
Download "The Snugglestorm" no
at Apple Podcasts.